andré et dorine un spectacle visuel
étonnant trois comédiens jouent plus de
quinze personnages sans prononcer un
seul mot
le coup de coeur du théâtre montansier
c'est assez étonnant de se rendre compte
de quelle manière le théâtre visuel
permet de raconter une histoire sans
mots à versailles la saison débute en
septembre avec un habitué thomas fersen
revient au théâtre montansier que de
création création le mot d'ordre
avec dix sept nouveautés le monde entier
outre de présenter les spectacles dans
le cadre de contrats de cession a
soutenu les compagnies financièrement
pour réussir à monter ses projets et
donc on s'est associés d'une parade est
très grand metteur en scène très repérer
et d'autre part à des artistes émergents
à qui on permet de réaliser leurs
projets et de monter leurs oeuvres des
mises en scène contemporaine d'oeuvres
classiques la saison sera rythmée par
molière william shakespeare georges
feydeau honoré de balzac ou encore
victor hugo nous on pense qu'au théâtre
c'est le lieu du texte et donc c'est
important de faire en tant que ces
pièces par exemple ruy blas monté par
yves beaunesne que l'on coproduit avec
les mines et les fêtes nocturnes de
grignan
on va entendre un grand victor hugo qui
n'est pas monté si souvent la scène
versaillaise accueillera aussi des
grands noms de la danse les italiens de
l'opéra de paris interpréteront
plusieurs extraits du répertoire de
l'institution jean claude gallotta
mettra en scène trente enfants de 12 à
17 ans le théâtre montansier connaîtra
aussi une nouveauté
[Musique]